buongiorno
a voi tutti il livello di mentale
dimostrerò mi dà un'idea precisa della
mia tarda età gli proporrò una
riflessione attorno a un insieme di
mentalità diffuse collettive italiane
che hanno a che fare con la biodiversità
con l'agricoltura il nostro mondo è
diventato moderno industrializzazione
esplosione del terziario eccetera in
tempi relativamente recenti ancora
all'altezza del censimento della
popolazione nel 1951
più della metà delle persone maschi e
femmine che lavoravano allora si
occupavano di agricoltura e quando si
pensa a qualcosa del genere viene in
mente una società molto all'antica di
che cosa ci occupiamo di che mondo il
mondo è l'italia settentrionale tutta
intera e la cintura delle tre regioni
alte del centro italia toscana umbria
marche
questo insieme a alti livelli di
coerenza ci sono moltissimi elementi
comuni ci sono alcuni luoghi lo vedremo
un po diversi ma sono molto piccoli
quando comincia questa storia dal xii
secolo non da ieri da ieri l'alto ma nel
tempo lontanissimo nella nostra
percezione quando la popolazione che
quel pezzo d'italia abitava era per 8 16
per cento nel tempo con oscillazioni
abitanti di città
per il resto 92 84 per cento erano
contadini che significa essere contadini
significa nascere vivere e morire sulla
terra lavorare la terra per c'è una
formula un po antica che dice sbarcare
il lunario cioè sopravvivere continuare
come famiglia come gruppo di generazione
in generazione coltivando la stessa
terra sfruttando la e ottenendo tutto
quello che serve che si consuma per
sopravvivere autarchia la famiglia
produce quel che consumerà e spera di
avere tutto quello che serve minimo di
scorte necessarie e sufficienti per non
tirare la cinghia per non dover
rivolgersi ad altri per avere quello che
non è riuscita a produrre
vi ricordo che all'inizio del secolo
scorso in italia tutta intera
solo il 17 per cento della popolazione
abitava in comuni che avevano più di 50
mila abitanti che vuol dire che
mancavano le grandi città o erano
pochissime e che la stragrande
maggioranza popolazione italiana era
radicata fuori dalle città lontano dalle
città e in montagna nelle valli nelle
colline moltissime nelle poche pianure
che c'erano otto decimi dei contadini
che consideriamo sono piccoli
proprietari possessori che continuano la
loro terra oppure sono mezzadri che
continuano la terra di qualcuno che
abita in città
molto spesso aristocratico ancor più
spesso borghese che affida la terra loro
perché era continuino e divide a metà i
racconti
i contadini contadini mezza dei
proprietari dunque praticano anche i
proprietari praticano l'autarchia
domestica cioè consumo sono riusciti a
raccogliere quando vendono se vendono
qualcosa è perché c'è un di più rispetto
alle esigenze di alimentazione e dunque
capitati vendono ma non producono per
vendere così come se c'è un incidente se
c'è un fallimento dei racconti e penso
soprattutto ai cereali che servono per
fare il pane è grande e fondamentale
presidio dell'alimentazione tradizionale
antica assieme al vino
dunque se non hanno prodotto abbastanza
dovranno fornirsi e allora dovranno
comprarlo
e allora se hanno avuto un'annata molto
favorevole saranno in piccola parte
venditori delle cedente se invece è
andata male se c'è stato un fallimento
del raccolto se c'è stato qualcosa che
somiglia a una carestia dovranno
comperare dunque il c'è una condizione
nella quale a seconda di situazioni che
loro non controllano si troveranno a
vendere
oppure si troveranno a comprare tutto
questo fa sì che non ci sia nulla che
somiglia al mercato moderno
capitalistico nel quale chi produce per
vendere lo fa calcolando e prevedendo
quale sarà il prezzo
ipoteticamente poco più poco meno che si
aspetta ci sia e chi compra compra
semplicemente per consumare perché fa
mestieri che non ha nulla a che fare con
l'agricoltura alla coltivazione del
terreno dunque l'arbitro delle
condizioni alimentari della vita
quotidiana dei contadini degli otto
decimi di tutti gli italiani
di tutti questi secoli è la meteorologia
è la combinazione buon tempo cattivo
tempo genere di suolo dunque siamo in
una condizione di soggezione e
incapacità di progettare immaginare
migliorare lungo quei secoli per
tentativi ed errori si identificano i
cereali che vale la pena in quel certo
luogo in quella certa campagna di
seminare nell'attesa che la raccolta
premi gli sforzi le fatiche e le
speranze dunque l'imprevedibile offerta
e domanda annuale di derrate agricole
nel caso italiano non danno luogo al
mercato convenzionalmente inteso mercato
dove il prezzo è il segnale che induce
chi produce per vendere a migliorare la
sua gestione contenere i costi per avere
un guadagno in prospettiva più alto o
fare investimenti per aumentare la
produzione prodotto e contenere i costi
dall'altra parte i consumatori che
osserva nei pressi che si danno e
comprano nel momento in cui l'esperienza
ha insegnato i prezzi tendenzialmente
caleranno appena effettuati raccolti
grande offerta prezzi calanti
dopo molti mesi quando si è in vista del
nuovo raccolto ma ancora non c'è stato
prezzi in crescita e dunque ci si
estendono a comprare si si si può
permettere di astenersi da comprare
ma c'è un altro protagonista di questa
storia del quale normalmente non si
tratta non si discute sono i comuni così
come i comuni cittadini molto ben
studiati hanno una loro come dire
politica economica molto precisa lo
stesso vale per i comuni sono migliaia
piccoli medi grandi molto grandi comuni
rurali quei comuni hanno poteri simili a
quelli di un piccolo stato
la dominante mentalità
autarchica delle famiglie fa sì che
anche il comune abbia una prassi
autarchica e dunque i comuni
istituiscono aziende speciali comunali
chiamate a non ha chiamate con una
varietà di parole che identificano una
riserva una scorta comune che viene
usata per permettere di comperare
qualche anno si è riusciti a prodotti a
produrre allora queste queste aziende in
annate di grandi raccolti comprano
questo di più di offerta che c'è per
impedire che pressi crollino e
sostengono ovunque i produttori e in
un'annata di carestia e intervengono
mettendo gettando sul mercato un'offerta
aggiuntiva per permettere anche ha
bisogno di mangiare il povero per
definizione che ha bisogno di
alimentarsi per sopravvivere di non
pagare prezzi folli per semplicemente
mangiare il pane dunque abbiamo una
strategia politica amministrativa mirata
a conservare la popolazione a permettere
di non cadere amenorrea da carestia
caduta dei concepimenti perché le donne
non mangiano abbastanza e dunque non
possono ovulare e dunque non avranno
possibilità di concepire i figli questa
è la prospettiva drammatica di un anno
di carestia
i buoni dunque permetteranno
eccezionalmente l'esportazione di
frumento dopo aver verificato tutte le
famiglie vengono intercettate devono
dichiarare quali sono le loro scorte
dopo aver intercettato la dimensione
generale delle scorte e permettono che
si esporti pagando licenze
quel di più che non serve per mantenere
popolazioni in vita allora abbiamo una
autonomia totale completa nei movimenti
delle merci di base
qualcosa del genere dura per moltissimo
tempo viene avanti per tutti i secoli
che vi ho ricordato è ancora nella
seconda metà dell'ottocento a
unificazione realizzata continuano i
comuni a mantenere queste autonomie
altissime tutto diverso lo scenario
fuori d'italia
nell'europa centro settentrionale perché
l'italia ha un primato negativo in fatto
di rese semino 1 quanto raccolgo nel
caso italiano ci accoglie se si semina 1
da tre a sei volte la semente dopodiché
togliete la semente per seminare
prossimo anno allora 3 diventa 2 e 6
diventa 5
ci sono alcune piccole isole citavo
prima che fanno eccezione ma sono molto
piccole
milano milanese lodigiano cremonese in
lombardia qui nelle venezie l'area del
padovano in romagna tra imola cesena in
pianura romagnola e in toscana nelle
campagne tra firenze e arezzo e siena
alcuni pochi luoghi nei quali non si è
tra tra esse emma ci si muove più vicino
a 68 ma lassù in inghilterra nelle
fiandre in russia in polonia
tutt'altra storia da 10 a 12 volte non
meno di 10 qualche volta appena un po
più di 12 c'è una costanza c'è una
regolarità di produzione che mette al
sicuro da carestie addirittura in
inghilterra si semina 1 si raccoglie 16
nell'inghilterra meridionale e
occidentale
l'ultima carestia inglese è del 1315 16
dopo di allora mai più visto una
carestia lunga condizioni totalmente
differenti
lassù nasce il mercato perché l'offerta
è stabile oscillazioni più o meno 10 12
per cento
qui da noi l'offerta è imprevedibile e
quando c'è il crollo dell'offerta i
prezzi impazziscono
dunque il mercato è percepito dalla
stragrande maggioranza degli italiani di
quel pezzo d'italia come qualcosa di
estraneo è pericoloso perché se non
hanno prodotto abbastanza devono
comprare pagheranno prezzi altissimi si
indebiteranno per sopravvivere
c'è una differenza c'è una diffidenza
diffusa nei confronti del mercato nel
nostro paese è una comune mentalità
diffusa che continua nel tempo ben oltre
l'uscita di scena di tutto questo ultimo
otto primi novecento
cominciano a migliorare le condizioni
produttive perché si usano concimi
chimici e il salto è notevole
dunque tutto questo fa sì che ci sia
come risultato una biodiversità
preservata di tutto un po produco
coltivo non mi sforzo più di tanto
perché è la meteorologia d'età il
responso che mi dà un po meno povero o
più ricco per quest'album i comuni sono
come dire allineati su questa mentalità
e si organizzano per evitare che ci sia
un crollo dei concepimenti la gente non
muore di fame normalmente ma quando ci
sono caldi i concepimenti la prossima
generazione può essere messo in
difficoltà perché non abbiamo abbastanza
braccia per lavorare la terra
sono piccoli gli appezzamenti ancora
oggi l'italia in europa nell'unione
europea ha il primato di piccole imprese
agricole
l'assenza di un mercato e di scambi
regolati i prodotti agricoli è
all'insegna tutto questo è all'insegna
della preoccupazione di preservare
all'interno degli abitanti del comune
che cosa le condizioni vulnerabili dei
più bisognosi dei più poveri di terra ci
sarà un processo di indebitamento nel
tempo molte famiglie dovranno vendere
anche l'ultimo pezzetto di terra per
poter sopravvivere diventeranno operai
operai numerosissimi nell'ottocento il
mio tempo è scaduto
vi ringrazio dell'attenzione e buon
proseguimento di questa giornata
strategicamente interessante